un atelier bande dessinée pour les
résidents de l'esat de trappes en
yvelines un événement en lien avec le
festival bd de buc objectif pour la
27ème édition rendre l'art accessible à
tous
on va toucher beaucoup de public ça peut
être des scolaires ça peut être des
publics empêchés ça peut être en tout
cas réunir toutes les forces locales
autour d'un projet autour d'un outil
redoutable qui est l'outil de la bd
aller 7 de la marsa vingt cinq personnes
en situation de handicap ont participé à
la première séance jeudi dernier c'est
vraiment une vraie découverte et puis
une vraie un vrai challenge pour eux et
puis un travail de groupe
voilà c'est on va dire c'est des moments
où ils se découvrent ils découvrent
d'autres d'autres capacités
par rapport à leur handicap par rapport
au fait de pouvoir être ensemble
les ateliers sont animés par la
dessinatrice de bandes dessinées céline
olive
elle intervient dans le cadre du
festival pour accompagner les
travailleurs handicapées
c'est vraiment en retrait très
enrichissant humainement on voit que ça
laisse à leur plaît mais comme c'est un
le dessin c'est universel en comics part
ça tout le monde comprend donc tout on
peut le faire aussi
au total l'atelier bd est composé de dix
séances le but
écrire un scénario et réaliser une
planche un travail complet on leur
demandait d'écrire une histoire delà de
la structure et il y en a qui n'ont
jamais dessiné donc il faut ça fait
quand même beaucoup d'un coup
donc en fait on les accompagne tout au
long et en fait on pour que ce soit
cohérent enfin qu'il y ait une petite un
petit lien entre les deux on leur
demande de raconter leur journée de
travail ou alors ce qu'ils aient les
bons moments qu'ils ont passés dans
l'établissement les dessins seront
exposés au festival bd de but qu il se
déroulera les 10 et 11 octobre prochains